At its core, suretyship is a contract where one party guarantees the performance or non-performance of a legal obligation imposed upon another party.
To understand this completely, you must separate it from standard insurance.
Insurance is a traditional two-party contract of indemnity. Suretyship is a three-party triangular transaction.
These three essential parties are: One, the principal, also known as the obligor. This is the party who secures the bond and owes the primary obligation, such as a contractor or an employee.
Two, the obligee, the ultimate beneficiary who requires the bond and to whom the obligation is owed.
Three, the surety, the insurance company backing the agreement and guaranteeing the obligation.
Because three parties are involved, suretyship relies on three distinct contracts executed in a specific sequence.
First is the principal contract between the principal and the obligee, which sets details of the work or legal requirement to be guaranteed.
Second is the surety bond itself, which establishes the legal liability of the surety to the obligee.
Third is the indemnity agreement between the surety and the principal.
This indemnity agreement changes the entire financial dynamic, making a surety bond a no-loss contract.
Under this agreement, the principal binds themselves solidarily to fully reimburse the surety for any expenses, legal fees, or payouts resulting from a claim.
Furthermore, while a standard insurance policy can be cancelled by either party, a surety bond is an accessory contract that cannot be cancelled unless the obligee gives explicit consent.
Finally, if a claim arises, non-payment of the premium by the principal is never a valid ground for the surety to deny the obligee's claim.
Now that the structural framework is clear, we can examine the specific types of bonds utilized across the industry. Let's move to the next chapter.